[Music]  do you want but tiny peas and cheese the  first thing I remember is Lucas she does  seem to really like you that's a sign  her home supposed to be with me think  I'm gonna call her Bella we played ball  and we played dough to shoes don't you  shoes that one was his favorite  oh it's just snow I had a great family  and a place to call home I was lost  duck looks like she needs help and a  long way from home Sherman Sophie  Sadie Bella food drop-off  [Music]  the world was far bigger or uncertain  than I could ever imagine  that dog saved his life  [Music]  when I'm wiser  Hey look a doggie  [Music]  I discovered that every challenge I met  every fear I faced brought me one step  closer to the place where I belong  [Music]  No  you